-"Newlywed Kitchen."
I guess I'm four years in now
to my marriage.
Does this still work for me?
-Oh, boy.
The recipes are so good.
-That's great.
What's difference --
What's the difference
between recipes for newlyweds
and people who have been married
for like 20 years?
-[ Chuckles ] Not much.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Not much.
-There's just
a little more enthusiasm.
You probably go into it
together and say,
"We should cook together."
-Smaller amounts.
-Okay.
-And it's when you really
do want to cook together.
And actually there's so many
great recipes in this book,
and it's beautiful.
-Yeah, well, it's
a Martha Stewart book.
-I don't think --
I'm cooking from it.
-Are you really?
-And I'm not a newlywed.
-This is interesting
that it's Game Day Chili,
because I think one half of
newlyweds don't love that.
-[ Laughs ]
-But that's all right. Maybe --
-They don't like game day,
you mean? Yeah, right.
-So let me ask you about this.
You were up at 5:00 a.m.
this morning.
-Ugh!
-You went to your
granddaughter's school
to make cookies.
-I did. I did.
-How'd it go?
-Well, I had to
bake the cookies.
Because they -- I was --
My job was to teach them
how to decorate gingerbread.
-Oh. Got it.
-So not a gingerbread house,
but gingerbread men.
Gingerbread trees.
Gingerbread gnomes.
And they had the greatest time.
-That is -- Just be jealous
for not having a school
that --
There you go. That's a better
way of showing that.
-That's better.
-I mean, that looks
like an assembly line.
-And that's my little
granddaughter right over there.
-Oh, that's fantastic.
-And she's like a little Martha.
We call her Little Martha.
-Yeah, there you guys are,
hard at work.
That's fantastic.
-And she loves to help
and do all those things.
-Gotcha. And are -- are kids
in that -- at that age
intimidated when
Martha Stewart comes in?
-No. They couldn't wait
to get to those cookies.
They couldn't wait
to get the pastry bags
and the tips and the spatulas
and everything.
-How did they do? Be honest.
How did they do?
-Most of them were
very artistic, actually.
-Oh, that's good.
-And -- And I have --
I'm gonna post some of their
pictures on my Instagram.
But they were very good cookies.
-All right.
-Yeah. And some were
a little sloppy.
And the mess!
The mess afterward.
Oh, yoy yoy. But it was --
But it was my fault
because I made the frosting
a little too thin.
-Oh, okay.
Well I think
it's a big step forward
that you're finally taking blame
for mistakes like that.
-I am. [ Laughs ]
I'm working on it.
-I feel like that's good.
-I'm working on it.
-So you -- This is -- there's
no blame to be had here.
You hosted a holiday party.
-You didn't come.
-I didn't come, but I --
-I invited you.
-Well, here's the thing.
I didn't know --
I wanted to see photos
of this year's
before I decided
about next year.
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean, this is --
Is this actually the kitchen
during your holiday party?
-That's my kitchen.
-I mean, look at that.
-We had four different
kinds of hams.
-Four different -- What are
the four kinds of ham?
-We had an ibérico ham.
We had a La Quercia ham
from the Midwest that --
They eat only acorns, the pigs.
-Oh, wow.
-And it's such a delicious ham.
And we had a country ham
from the Loveless Motel
down in Nashville.
-Oh, my God.
-Have you ever had that?
-No.
-Ah, the best.
-And we had a Pat LaFrieda ham.
-That's fantastic.
-And they were all
cooked differently.
And they were all gone.
I don't even have a ham bone.
I don't know who took the bones.
-You didn't --
-I want the bones!
-Those ungrateful S.O.B.'s
didn't even leave you
the ham bone?!
-How many -- How many cookies
were at your party?
-We did -- I think --
My granddaughter told me
it was 1,001 cookies
that we made.
-Wow.
-And look how cute they are.
-They're really nice.
-Yeah, they're really cute.
-Now be honest.
Would you have had
the fifth-grade cookies
here at this?
-No.
-Yeah, okay, good.
-Jude's maybe. Jude's.
-Okay. Gotcha.
So, a couple questions
about holiday parties.
Some Martha Stewart rules.
If you're going to a holiday
party, are you supposed to
bring something and
what's a good thing to bring?
-Well, you don't
have to take anything.
But -- Because my house --
I mean, you should see
my front hall.
-Yeah.
-It's like -- like --
so many presents.
And I'm kind of embarrassed
because I don't need anything.
-Yeah. Well, that's the thing.
I would --
I would feel so much pressure
trying to think of,
what does Martha Stewart need
that she didn't go out
and get herself?
-No, no. I don't get things.
I'm not like that.
I'm not -- I'm not --
I don't have to get things.
-Yeah, they just show up.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-But I don't want to say
that you're just sitting here
being inactive
and things are showing up.
Because you did something
that I would not do
and I am so impressed.
You plow your own driveway.
-I do.
I have a four-mile driveway.
-Yeah.
-I mean really, truly --
I live on a farm,
so there's four miles of roads.
And I actually love --
It's like flying an airplane.
When you get into a truck
with a plow,
you can't think of anything else
'cause, you know,
can't go off the road.
You'll hit the stakes.
And you don't want
to hit anything.
-So you're dialed in.
-I'm dialed in.
And I just plow for like --
Four hours it takes to do --
-No! Four hours?
-It does. Because
you have to go one way
and then you have to
come back the other way.
-So two hours each way.
-Yes.
-But you got stuck.
This is an Instagram.
You said, "I went to plow,
and I got stuck."
-Then I had to get pulled out by
the Kawasaki or whatever we had.
-Now, yeah, so, are you
embarrassed when you --
Does panic set in?
-No! No, it's natural.
-Yeah.
-It's one of those things.
-It's not natural.
-[ Laughs ]
-This is a manmade machine.
That's not --
-No, it's natural to get stuck.
-Yeah, it is natural
to get stuck.
-I mean, my plow guys,
they don't get stuck.
-Right.
How do your plow guys feel
about the fact that you're
doing it by yourself?
-They're happy, probably,
because they're inside
drinking hot coffee
while I'm out
plowing in the freezing cold.
-What's your -- What's --
We're gonna make some drinks,
some holiday drinks
just in a second.
-Oh, I can't wait. I can't wait.
-Do you have a favorite?
-Well, let's --
We'll wait and talk about --
-One of the drinks has cachaca,
which is my favorite.
-Cachaca? What's cachaca?
-It's that
Brazilian cane liqueur.
-You have a favorite liquor
that's a Brazilian cane liquor?
-Yep.
-You are living the best life.